and speaking of something good i'm now
going to show you a
ad from the russian army and
this video went viral as i said because
somebody looped it together
with an ad from the american army and
it's an incredible
just a truly incredible juxtaposition
of the way one country behaves in a
serious manner and
the way another country behaves
unfortunately the united states in a
completely
unserious manner this was retweeted by
all sorts of people including ted cruz
and then of course he started
getting called a russian asset and
everything else so first let's show you
this
russian army video
is
[Music]
all right i don't speak russia but
russian but i assume he was saying
something to the effect of you know
we're
serious people and i've got to go do
something and i'm fighting for my
country and
that's what we're going to go do i also
think dan was it dan snyder
zack snyder zack snyder of justice
league probably directed that thing
you can see you don't even need to know
exactly what he's saying to understand
and whether you think it's propaganda or
not we can have all of those debates
but what you're seeing is the russian
government is putting out an ad saying
we want soldiers we want to be able to
defend our country
we're going to do what we got to do now
allow me to show you what the u.s army
put out last week
it begins in california with a little
girl
raised by two moms i also marched for
equality
i like to think i've been defending
freedom from an early age
standing at the altar to marry my other
mom
with such powerful role models i
finished high school at the top of my
class
i found it a way to prove my inner
strength
and maybe shatter some stereotypes along
the way
i'm us army corporal emma malonelord and
i answered my calling
we're screwed people you get it you get
it like can you
imagine that russian guy coming up
against that girl
no offense to that girl no offense to
her lesbian mothers
no offense to the marching no offense to
equality
no offense to any of that but if you
give me
a you know east village lesbian vs
vladimir putin
who's gonna win what are we doing what
are we doing
that's great nobody cares if you're gay
nobody cares if you're straight nobody
cares if you're trans
but which one of those seems like a
country that is that is saying we
we are here we are here for a purpose we
are here to defend ourselves we are here
because we believe
in the the documents that got us here
and we are
strong and don't mess with us and all of
that stuff
now again maybe the russian one is
propaganda
i'm not gonna sit here i'm not gonna sit
here and defend a russian army ad
right although i would defend ivan drago
fighting uh rocky balboa
uh in moscow on christmas day in 1985 i
believe that was
um but it's just like you see these two
things do we have a problem here like
we got a real problem here and we're
gonna have to figure out how to deal
with that
by the way this is fantastic connor
showed me this my director showed me
this right before
we started on that youtube video on the
us army ed now they shut off comments so
you're not allowed to comment on that
but this is
absolutely incredible there are 4.2
000 so 4 200 likes
4.2 000 likes 86
000 dislikes is this are we inspiring
people
are we inspiring people i don't know you
know you can only
garner or glean that much information
from likes on youtube videos but like
something ain't right and again i just
want to say
fantastic work with that cartoon girl
and her lesbian mothers nobody's
that's wonderful it's great not that
there's anything wrong with that it's
just wonderful
but i think putin's got a leg up on us
like putin's watching that video going
we're okay guys don't worry invasion
begin next week okay